because changing some of the western
blots and some of the bands were
surrounded by weird rectangles or they
were like lines that did not make quite
sense and they were very reluctant and
and did not really share original Bloods
uh and and a couple of times they did
show original Bloods those appear to
have been photoshopped
so it's it's it's still ongoing the the
company just filed the lawsuit today so
that's why I'm a little bit careful
they're obviously very concerned about
defamation
but it's uh yeah it's uh it's you know
it's going to be a long story and it's
going to take a lot of time to figure
all of this out but I agree that the the
concerns I feel are realistic and I
would love to see original data but the
company instead um is filing a lawsuit
against the people who originally filed
the complaints so hello and welcome to
the cheeky science show where in this
video I spoke with Elizabeth Beck a
former microbiologist who has worked at
the Dutch National Institute of Health
and the school of medicine at Stanford
University
who is now a science Integrity
consultant Where She searches the
biomedical literature for
inappropriately duplicated or
manipulated photographic images
plagiarized text or poor studied design
and data analysis
Elizabeth's work has been featured in
nature science the New York Times The
Wall Street Journal and now the cheeky
Science Show so let's get on with the
conversation
so hi Elizabeth thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the Shiki science
show it's great to have you on
I'm so happy to hear you here uh let's
talk exactly yeah because I'm I've never
really spoken about uh scientific
misconduct before in a channel but
obviously it's such a huge part of
anyone who's a part of Science and
Beyond and um I just think you have so
many important lessons and stories to
tell us and a lot that I mean I could
learn from you and I'm sure some of my
audience members can too
um and I decided to wear a white T-shirt
for this conversation too because I know
that you have a special skill at
spotting patterns and I didn't want to
distract you until
um but before we get on to that I just
wondered if you could provide um for my
audience who maybe don't know your
backgrounds
um what is your background to science
and what were some kind of triggers that
made you sort of steer away from the
basic science research more to know
doing a scientific integrity
uh yeah I'm Elizabeth big I um I was
born and did my PhD in the Netherlands
so I'm I'm from Europe and I moved to
the US 21 years ago
and I have a background in microbiology
so I have a PhD in microbiology works on
cholera on tuberculosis I've worked in a
clinical lab in a hospital and then when
I moved to the US I worked for 15 years
at Stanford
and I worked on the microbiome of humans
and dolphins and so I also started a
Blog called microbiome digest so for
people who are in the microbiome field I
wanted to have a daily update on the new
papers in the field and that blog is now
currently run by a team of volunteers so
I don't do it anymore but I started it
and then during my my work at Stanford I
got interested in science Integrity
first in plagiarism and then by accident
I discovered this this duplication in a
PhD thesis that had plagiarized texts
but it also had duplicated photos of
Western Bloods and I realized I have
some Talent of spotting duplications in
photos in scientific papers and I
started doing that as a hobby and then I
just I just liked it more than my real
work and so I um after doing that for a
couple of years in 2019 I quit my job I
worked at the biotech company at that
time
and I am now a full-time consultant I
guess on volunteer
um and I uh yeah I worked on on finding
more examples of duplicated images in
scientific papers
and so when you talk here about
scientific misconduct what do you
actually mean by that and I know that um
there's ways that maybe you can classify
different types of misconducts
they're well I'm looking for problems in
images mostly and not all of those are
misconduct so some are just errors where
people might have accidentally included
the same photo twice
but misconduct is is usually defined as
one of three things plagiarism
falsification or fabrication so
plagiarism that's usually refers to text
um where somebody copies somebody else's
text or ideas and doesn't give credit
um and that is usually related to text
but but I focus on falsification
fabrication where falsification is where
somebody does an experiment
but leaves out a value or makes the
value a little bit better uh you know
that increases the value so it becomes a
positive for example from a negative
and then fabrication is where a person
completely makes up results so for
example you can type in some beautiful
numbers in a spreadsheet to make a
beautiful graph without actually doing
experiments so that is definitely not
good that is science misconduct and with
images
um for example if you would Photoshop an
image I I'm not even sure if you would
call that fabrication or falsification
you're making up results so you could
you could technically say it's a
fabrication but maybe a result had been
obtained it was just older so you could
also classify that as falsification so
I'm not quite sure which of the two it
is but it is it would count as science
misconduct for sure it's not the result
that somebody actually had obtained they
uh they've yeah they added or they
removed some of the data and and thus
that's not that's not good science
exactly and so I think the first kind of
introduction of the first sort of case
study that I came across regarding This
was
um the sort of famous I think it was
2014 study with stem cells in Japan
um where they discovered these stem
cells where they could have Rejuvenation
with some chemical uh formula but it
turned out that it was completely
um
unreproducible and so I was just
wondering if you could maybe talk about
some big cases that were quite shocking
for you to come across and
um yeah the ones that have been most
surprising
yeah there's many cases there's whole
Wikipedia sites with cases of misconduct
and so it's uh it's uh quite interesting
to read and misconduct happens in any
any field of science
um so in the Netherlands where I'm from
we had a very famous case
where
um a person working in Psychology at
tilburg University and his name was
dieterichstaple he even admitted to
completely fabricating his results so he
did all these kinds of Investigations in
school children or adults he
investigated he did all these
experiments but he made up all these
results he never did those actual
experiments so this is fabricated
results
and I've I believe around 50 5-0 of his
papers have been retracted and he
admitted that he made it up like I'm
yeah so that's that's a case that shook
the Netherlands because it was is he was
always in the news and and you know he
was like very famous uh and and so he
made up all these all these results
and then another case that uh is worth
mentioning is the falsification of the
work of Andrew Andrew Wakefield
he published a paper in oh well I think
90 in the 1990s I believe
where he claimed that the MMR vaccine
caused autism in small children and he
presented 12 children and sort of made
it look like they all got autism after
they have received the vaccine while in
reality he falsified some of the data he
yeah he made stuff up he he changed a
lot of the results to make the results
fit his hypothesis and as the result of
that paper the Wakefield paper which got
retracted 12 years later after it was
proven that this data had been falsified
uh as the result of that paper a lot of
people believed that he was right and
were very worried about the consequences
of vaccinating their kids and so a lot
of people said I'm not going to
vaccinate my kids and a lot of kids got
measles and and probably some people
died as the result of that uh definitely
lots of more children had been
hospitalized after that paper came out
and he still has a big influence on
um on public health because there's
still a big anti-vax movement and he's
very active in that and so this paper
was based on misconduct and had very
far-reaching consequences
yeah no that is that's incredibly
shocking I didn't actually know that
case and so I mean in that in that
situation I know that you did do you
published a study in 2018 or 2016 that
looked at some of the reasons that
someone might perform misconduct and so
yeah why why would someone do this and
what are the sort of more common reasons
that you see
well it all goes back to the pressure to
publish which most of us scientists feel
whether we're a graduate student or a
professor we we feel pressure from above
to publish papers and and to publish
them in high impact journals and to
publish positive results it's very hard
as we all know to publish negative
results and and so it's very tempting
especially with digital photography
to change the results to make them look
a little bit better because now we have
a better chance of getting our papers
published and we have a better chance of
getting a ladder of recommendation or
get tenure so most of our career
opportunities are tied to the number of
papers we publish and also Academia is
very
um you know there's a hierarchy
structure that is very rigid and imagine
that you work for a bully as a professor
and that bully that Professor has a very
strict hypothesis and does not want to
hear any results that do not fit the
hypothesis this professor might put a
lot of pressure on their grad students
or their postdocs to give him or her
certain results that fit that hypothesis
and they might use threatening language
such as I'm going to fire you or I'm
going to hire another postdoc who can
produce these results
and so this professor might not directly
Photoshop images themselves or or do any
other you know types of misconduct but
the the people working for him or her
might feel very pressure to to change
the results so you see sometimes these
these uh papers from a group of uh
specific research group and they all
have the same last author the same
senior person but different first author
result of authorship so
that sort of suggests to me that this is
a lab where there's a lot of bullying
and harassment and and if you don't
publish or this or if you don't obtain
those results I will fire you so there's
that is I think a very specific example
of why people might feel that the only
way out of that lab with a paper is to
uh is to falsify or fabricate results
I see yeah and so I mean
given that information I mean how
um you obviously can detect things such
as
um images or Western blots and how they
can get changed but I feel like even
like within the past five years more and
more papers these days have a lot of
computational analyzes and multi-mic
approaches and so when it comes to being
able to detective misconduct
um happens what do we do in these
situations where it's maybe not so easy
to spot it
yeah you raise an excellent point it is
much easier I feel to to catch my
misconduct in in photos or in images in
general but in plots line graphs uh
tables
um whatever data can be presented in it
has you know many different forms it's
much harder to detect it so if you think
about a line graph like I said
previously you can type in some numbers
and make a beautiful line graph with all
the dots nicely on the line or you can
make a bar graph or a Venn diagram a
heat map organization plot you could
present sequence data you could present
tables and it's very hard to spot
misconduct uh in in those types of data
so I'm focusing on images I can I can I
might see overlapping images for example
or cells that have been duplicated in a
photo but in other types of data it is
much harder to detect so there are some
ways um some people have developed some
statistical tools to analyze data in
tables or so but it's very
um slow like you you need to usually you
cannot really get the data you have to
hand type in all the numbers from the
tables and then do some analysis and
maybe you can catch for example
things like um all the shine all the
standard deviations are 10 of the mean
or the average value and I've seen those
things and those are quite easy to catch
but if it's really sophisticatedly done
there's almost no way to detect it
the example like the reason for why
someone might do it
um you said the pressure to publish and
that being in a very academic setting
but is misconduct then just limited to
Academia or has also seen in industry
it's also seen in Industry I'm sure but
um eventually an industry usually it it
will research will lead to some product
like a drug and I don't think you can
really
fake whether a drug works or not so
there might be and I've seen examples of
that where you see suspected
manipulation of data or images or
whatever in pre-clinical research but in
the end the the the you know the final
test is whether a drug works or not and
I think that's very hard to cheat you
can although I've seen some there was
some recent talk about a group of people
at a clinical research side to faked
results but in the end those things
would come out so it's not impossible
but it's much harder once it has reached
the clinical stage like the phase two
and phase three trials and you see that
often those drugs fail at those phases
they might look incredibly well in phase
one and two but then in phase three when
it's really large numbers they they fail
and so not saying that that is
misconduct but but it is very hard to to
to um to cheat in whether your drug
Works in thousands of patients I feel
that's that's impossible
but I'm sure there's lots of
you know that like the in biotech same
as in in any startup there's this push
to exaggerate your data to over promise
a little bit right we we know like you
you want to as a in a in a yeah in a
company you want to impress your
investors you want to get more money so
it's it's sort of almost accepted to
exaggerate your results a little bit and
to over promise but with biotech it is
very hard to over promise I mean if you
work on let's say
um a cell phone and you over promise
that you can make a camera that can
capture I don't know so many pixels or
so like you could over promise but you
you might actually be able you know a
year from now to technically advance to
that level
but with whether or not a drug works you
cannot really
make a promise and then sort of EX to
push the boundaries and make the drug
better I feel it's harder to cheat in
BIO attack in the end you you have to be
more much more realistic in what you
promise because you cannot push the
boundary as much as you can in other
technical fields yeah I see and I guess
like someone on from that how how many
bi-tech companies do you think are
somewhat maybe based on some misconduct
or some
um incorrect data to begin with so I
guess the kind of example I'm trying to
lead towards is there's been a lot of
talk about Alzheimer's disease
um recently and I know that I think
you've been following uh the case and
say would you be able to lose a day it's
a bit about what's going on and the
Alzheimer's bills
I have no idea what the percentage would
be uh or the the absolute number I'm I'm
sure there's cheating everywhere in any
company in any field whether it's
science or or you know other companies
uh you know we we have seen financing
banking construction there's there's
fraud everywhere so I'm sure it happens
in biotech as well
um with regards to alzheimer's I mean
that's a very important topic
Alzheimer's disease affects you know not
not all of us like directly but I think
all of us it's safe to say that all of
us know people with Alzheimer's and have
been maybe very close to a person like
that in our families
and so it's a disease for which there's
no current good medicine yet so it's a
very important topic that I'm sure a lot
of people want to solve this problem
want to find a drug that helps against
Alzheimer's we all want that and I want
that too it's but there have I think
with with a important field like that
where there's lots of money to be
obtained from from Grants or from fun
funders or Venture capitalists I think
this might lead to some people feeling
that you could cheat and they got some
money and they can you know cheat the
results but
um so we have seen some
companies where there have been
suggestions that there was misconduct
okay but yeah it did at least the one
I've been involved with is a company
where that relies heavily on scientific
papers with that contain Western blots
which are protein Bloods which you know
are photos so that's one of the
um one of the Specialties one of the
things I specialize in and so I I agreed
there was a petition filed online where
people said well these Western blots
look
look um I don't know strange like
there's there's something weird about
them and I looked at them and I agreed
with those allegations
whether or not the company itself knows
this because this was like sort of a
almost like a contractor a scientist who
was hired to do this research so it
appears that this scientist
might have been and I'm very carefully
wording this obviously but there there
were signs of image problems with these
papers and so I'm not sure if the
company itself is involved in it but
definitely the scientists who was doing
this work appears to have perhaps been
yeah changing some of the western Bloods
and some of the bands were surrounded by
weird rectangles or there were like
lines that did not make quite sense and
they were very reluctant and and did not
really share original Bloods uh and and
the couple of times they did show
original blots those appear to have been
photoshopped
so it's it's it's still ongoing the the
company just filed the lawsuit today so
that's why I'm a little bit careful
they're obviously very concerned about
um
deformation
but it's uh yeah it's uh it's you know
it's going to be a long story and it's
going to take a lot of time to figure
all of this out but I agree that the the
concerns I feel are realistic and I
would love to see original data but the
company instead is filing a lawsuit
against the people who originally filed
the complaints right so
and so when are you like um normally
spot these um like these Western blots
manipulations or image manipulations
um what is the process between you
finding the the the deed I guess and
then it actually being a paper that gets
retracted what are the sort of
in-between steps and what sort of
barriers do you face along the way
um well many barriers so um I I look at
the images and first of all usually
nowadays I post these on pop here which
is a website where you can post concerns
about papers and those can be image
concerns or other concerns or
compliments but those are very rare and
so I will Mark the the photos saying
this this photo this panel looks
remarkably similar to that panel or this
cell looks very similar to that cell in
the same photo and I'll mark these
things with I usually put colored boxes
around them and sort of Mark them and
and hopefully make it clear to other
people that there's there's a concern
and I encourage the authors to send in
the original photos to take away my
concerns and that rarely happens
but officially this is of course not an
official way of reporting these things
officially you're I write to the editors
of the the journals in which the papers
have been published and right and they
then should contact the authors and and
ask for the original data or ask for an
explanation and but that's unfortunately
doesn't always lead to anything and you
know there's many reasons that authors
maybe not reply or the editors doesn't
do not agree with my findings and so I
found an original set of 800 papers
that only one third of them gets
corrected or retracted so if there's a
real concern it could just be an honest
error but then the paper needs to have a
correction with the correct figures but
if it's a real concern where there's a
suspected case of misconduct where you
know cells have been photoshopped within
the same photo for example then that
paper should be retracted but
retractions and Corrections do not
happen very often so only in one third
of the cases there was action taken and
two-thirds of these cases are still not
being flagged of you know still out
there without a correction or retraction
and does it vary as well depending on
the journal that you you find it or some
journals easier to like work with than
others
it's it's hard to tell I feel that
journals
um there have been some journals that
did not respond at all to when I sent
them a bunch of papers
but there have also been journals where
they made a pretty fast decision in some
papers but with other papers they just
did not seem to want to take in a step
or some action
so it might be that you know of the
papers where the authors didn't reply
for example or were you know could not
be found anymore because they had
changed institutions for example that in
those cases they just did not follow up
and so it's hard to say if a specific
Journal did better or worse than others
it seemed to be more dependent per paper
okay and so speaking of channels in
terms of like the scientific publishing
process
um I think a lot of my fears probably
aren't really aware of what happens
between some a group of scientists um
submitting some research and finally
getting published onto the the journal
sites and so there's things like peer
review that goes on
um and like accept reject decisions and
as you said um a fewer comments and then
revisions but would you be able to lose
dates on like the process of publishing
a paper and why certain things aren't
picked up during this peer review
process
it's because peer review is not really
set up to find misconduct I think a lot
of peer reviewers while peer review is
usually done as a sort of a volunteer
task something that most academics feel
they need to do and of course it's fair
because we want our papers also to be
peer-reviewed
but it's unpaid and and
the demands on peer reviewers are
getting higher their uh appears to be
you know people used to were asked like
this to peer review let's say two papers
a year and now it's like one every week
or so like I feel the demand has gone up
because I feel not a lot of divert
there's not a lot of diversity in um in
peer reviewers like it's the same people
being asked all over again
um but that aside like it's it's the
manuscripts also got bigger and longer
and more complex and I feel as a peer
reviewer it's getting harder every day
to peer review
because these papers are so long there's
like I don't know 60 supplemental
figures like how can I even wrap my
brain around that and and they're
multi-disciplinary much more than they
were let's say 10 or 20 years ago so
papers get much more complex and I feel
as a peer reviewer I can review one part
of the paper but not 10 other parts of
the papers and so you need more more
payer reviewers almost so
and then it's hard to look at the images
and and think of images as or or just
think of the whole manuscript with the
idea of could this have been fabricated
I feel most peer reviewers assume that
the paper is is real like they'll
they'll search for Flaws and and better
interpretation of the data but they
don't
look at the paper with the idea that it
could have been
made up and I of course look at that
maybe from a different point of view but
it's something that most pay-per-viewers
are not aware of they might just not
look at the data that way I'm trying to
to post things online on on Twitter and
to make people aware of like look
there's an image there's something very
wrong with it can you spot it and then
the first person who replies might get
an emoji award by me so I try to teach
people like there's a big problem with
the paper with the image look at it from
a different point of view because once
you've seen these examples of
photoshopping or or duplications or
overlapping photos
I feel yeah once you're aware you'll see
them faster so
um so I I hope that also peer reviewers
are backed up by by some editorial
assistance from the journal I feel a
paper should not just be peer-reviewed
but it should also be
judged or analyzed by a professional
person who's paid for things like
statistical statistical concerns
or is there ethical approval is there
you know are the the mice the animals
being treated fairly there's many things
many ways to look at a paper that a
specialist could do better than just one
peer review or two peer reviewers so I
hope that journals will
have some professionally hired persons
looking at papers as well once they get
accepted for example they just scan them
quickly for a range of potential
problems
and how many like specialized people
actually are there and how much I mean
funding seems to be an issue and what
funding even is available for people to
do what it is that you do
there's not much funding or awards for
you know for um finding problems in
papers I feel most signs uh grants and
and awards are geared towards finding
novelty just think about the Nobel Prize
it goes you know and fairly so we want
science to advance and we want
signs to find new things and and build
our research on that but I do feel that
some funding should go to
reproducibility to making sure that
science is good and to find errors and
and find make signs better in general
but some people argue you know that I
the work that I do and many others
actually also
um that the work we do is not making
science it's breaking science it's it's
it's you know weeding out errors and and
they might not think that that's
important I disagree with that I think
it's very important because we we need
science to be good because we base our
research on the work of others so
if papers contain errors or misconduct
then other people might waste a lot of
time trying to pursue that Avenue so I
feel it's very important to to have some
some type of error detection
um in science and and to make to flag
papers that have potential problems
exactly you know I completely agree and
the other thing you made me think of was
I've had a few conversations with people
about this obviously because I'm so like
very early in my career stage but how in
terms of like career progression it's
often looking at the number of papers or
the number of citations in your papers
and impact factor but how maybe we
should start to be considering
um you know having like publishing
negative data which I know is less
exciting but maybe that should be a
factor that's taken into account when
looking at
um hiring different people and I was
just wondering what are your thoughts in
terms of like improving the current
system and making misconducts less
common or like making the detection
better
well big question
yeah yeah I mean I I one of the the
things I've been discussing in in my job
in during my talks is that we should
uh we should have some reward system for
people being able to replicate science
studies so one of the ways you could
achieve that is uh for graduate students
in their first year of doing their
research not starting up a new project
but first replicating somebody else's
work
and and we should then
award that by uh you know giving credit
to that like for example on your resume
you should not just have your papers or
your talks but also the papers you have
been able to to reproduce
um and
uh once you're a little bit later in
your career papers that you wrote that
others have been able to reproduce
and I feel that there should be credits
given to that not only that I could
replicate somebody else's paper but that
my paper was replicated about us that
should be worth something and we should
we should give credit for that
and we should also have journals
accepting reproducibility studies we are
making a start with that by
pre-registering clinical studies because
very often you promise that you'll
publish the results whether or not the
outcome was good or bad you know if
there is a negative result we should
still want to hear whether a drug worked
or not that is very valuable information
you don't want other people to reinvent
the wheel
so I also hope we go to smaller
experimental Publications so for example
micro Publications where you just
publish one figure you just say okay
this is you know the PCR I did and this
is I did it on 100 samples and this is
the outcome what what would maybe
typically be one figure in a paper
publish that and then have other people
being able to replicate that and we we
don't need to really have journals for
that we can have
we can have other people replicated and
that sort of increases the value of an
experiment and
maybe we should think outside of the box
of classical Publications because
scientific publishing has become this
this very expensive monster that you
know we we I always say we write the
papers for free WE peer review them for
free and then we have to pay to get them
published it doesn't make any sense like
journalism wouldn't work that way right
um people in the New York Times get get
paid for their for for their uh
for their work and and we as scientists
don't get paid we actually have to pay
the publisher to get our results
published and
and so you would hope that some of that
money would go to
a quality control but it doesn't because
we're finding all these these problems
in in periods so-called peer-reviewed
papers we're finding lots of problems
still left
and it also doesn't seem to go to
customer service when I knock on the
door if a publisher and I say hey
there's a problem with this particular
paper
they very often do not answer or they
gave a vague answer but they don't
actually correct it and so there's no
very limited quality control at least
from my point of view I'm sure they will
say that they do lots of quality control
but it could be much better and I can
see these things just by using my eye I
can see there's a big problem with the
paper and so why didn't they pick that
up and also why don't they respond to
these allegations a little bit faster
why does it take five years to retract a
paper or even longer that doesn't make
any sense so
um I hope we can abandon partially the
the classical scientific publishing
model and go towards newer system that
are better a better fit for these times
where you just do things online and you
have other people comment on it
I think that will make much better signs
in the end
exactly yeah I think I mean at least
from the conversations I've had there
seems to be a lot of
um like as a kind of similar mindset so
you're saying right you do something and
immediately you can just paste it online
and have other people say it and
comments on it so that's even a site
that I'm somewhat involved in called
research Hub I'm not sure if you've come
across it but they have some sort of um
it's based on blockchain technology so
there's some sort of incentive that if
you publish and then comments on other
people's research then over time you're
incentivize through some sort of coin
value to do it so I think that's one
model that hopefully will have some
value but at the moment if you talk
about it to other professors they look
at you like you're crazy like this seems
so different to the current
um way in which science has published
and speaking of journals though just um
the other week E-Life announced that
they were gonna stop doing
um the exact rejects the decision
process I wasn't entirely sure what the
story was but um where you are aware of
this and would you be able to explain
what it is advanced
I've heard on it about it on Twitter but
I haven't looked into it yet I had some
other big timeline deadlines coming up
so uh and I'm actually I I need to fully
disclose I'm on the ethical Board of
E-Life but I this came as a surprise I
had no idea
um I'm not quite sure I feel there are
some papers that should be or some
manuscripts that should be desk rejected
just because they're crazy because they
they're not they don't have any
scientific value so I'm not quite sure
if they will still do you know some
initial screening because you know you
you don't want to accept everything that
comes that is sent your way
um I've also always peer reviewed from
with the idea of making a paper better
not to break a Dharma to make it better
and my peer reviews have been very long
and critical but but it is with that
mindset like we should we should Elevate
this paper to the level where it feels
it can be published
but having said that there are some
papers that are just not not ready like
there might be signs of misconduct there
might be signs of
complete wrong experimental design that
is beyond saving so
um but having said that I'm not quite
familiar with their new rules or
regulations or whatever you you want to
call that so I'm I haven't I don't know
all the details but from what I've heard
it doesn't sound like a very good idea
but I might be very wrong
and uh and I'm sure Michael Eisen has uh
you know as he's at least Innovative and
has good ideas so I I do feel we need to
you know improve scientific publishing
but I don't feel that every paper should
be
should be publishable
you know you can think of thinkors that
are have a very like a political agenda
where
where people say okay this this this
paper proves that the vaccine uh some
vaccine is causing autism even though
that that is completely wrong and the
design of the study is not not meant to
really investigate that so there are
just studies that
don't have a good experimental setup or
you know the control group
is very different at the start of the
experiment from the treatment group like
that's beyond saving like you cannot
save
flaws like that like if you know there
should be reasons to reject a paper for
that ground but yeah so but I I
definitely should read more about this
because I don't exactly know what the
rules will be
okay yeah nice fair enough um and
sometimes you mentioned you've done all
these um been a reviewer on many papers
if someone like candid your paper
um as like as a PC student someone who's
trying to find different papers and and
reading as much as I can but how do I
know if I look at a paper if this is
going to be a good paper and what are
the sort of like signs that this is
worth my time to really fully invest and
read it or should I quickly Skip and
read for something different
um it depends on a little bit on the
study so when it's let's say a group a
study where patients are being treated
with a drug you have like the basic
control group and treatment group I
think there's very basic
things you can check for are the con
like I just said it's the control group
at the start of the experiment very
different from the treatment group
that's that's a big no like you you want
to start with two groups that are
roughly equal and they're not going to
be perfectly equal but you know in terms
of age or or
um underlying disease or gender ratio
um so there's all these things you can
check for so that's very basic um and
you know that would be specifically for
a you know group of animals or arguments
that are being treated with a drug
for basic research you can also think
like what is
yeah is the set of samples
representative for the question you're
going to ask so if those things are all
good that's a good start but then
if you're asking me how to detect
misconduct that is a very difficult
question and I you know I I can look at
images and I can tell you the images
look good but that doesn't necessarily
mean that the paper is is real it could
still be fake
I've seen many papers that are
completely fake and you could see it
because they the authors made a fatal
flaw made some design error and you can
just see okay this paper is completely
fake but you know if they haven't made
that error I would not have been able to
tell you so there's there's some basic
things you can look for but then there's
many other things that you like even
experience peer review would miss
so it's it's it's very hard to know for
sure that a paper is good
yeah I mean actually you mentioned
something
um that I learned a lot only recently in
terms of fake papers and something
called paper mills and how um there are
these Saturn sites or certain like um
places where people can just generate
um completely fake data and so yeah
what's that about
so yeah paper mills are are
companies that or well the product of
companies that sell papers that are uh
either completely made up or they're
plagiarized things like that so there's
different models there are paper mills
that
uh that so companies that take papers
that's have been published in some local
language
let's say Russian or so or
Arabic and and that are not in the
mainstream English literature
um yeah they're not available for for
other parts of the world and they will
translate that text into English and
they change it maybe something or they
will take an English text
and then synonymize it and so you get
all these weird phrases like bosom Peril
which is breast cancer so that's one
type yeah and it's those papers are so
they're called tortured phrases and
Guillaume cabanak and some other people
have worked on that and they found tons
of papers that are appear to be
plagiarized but they're you wouldn't
find it directly because the text has
been everywhere it almost has been
synonymized
so that's that's one type of sort of
Paper Mill These are mass produced and
they're sold to authors uh then there
are papers that have been accepted maybe
because they the authors paid the
editor-in-chief because they had like
this special issue they had to write and
collect a lot of papers for and then
these special issues are
um usually have very low quality papers
and there might be Financial contract
between the editor and the the paper
mill contractor and then authors are
added to these accepted papers so these
uh Anna Albertina for example has worked
on these paper mills there there's one
that's active in Russia so she has
observed that papers were being offered
for sale like this paper has been
accepted and we have two authorship
spots available if you want to be the
first author you pay a little bit more
but you know you'll you can you get it
so this authors are added to already
accepted papers and then the third type
of paper mills that I've seen those are
active in in China where uh very
specifically for medical doctors working
at a clinical Hospital not research
institutions but clinical hospitals who
need papers for their promotion or their
you know to be offered a position at
these hospitals and they will buy
authors authorships unfabricated papers
that look very realistic so they might
have photos of of gels or
microscopy photos of cells or tissues
but you can see that these photos have
been are F you can find them in multiple
papers so if you know what to look for
you might recognize hey that photo has
been used in one paper to represent I
don't know
a ovarian cancer cell line but in this
paper in another paper by completely
different authors the same photo is
being used to represent the prostate
cancer cell line and wow they're like
wait that's weird and
and so these photos are sort of like
stock photos they're being used in
different papers and these papers are
believed to be completely fabricated
so I mean it's
our awareness I don't say a lot in Parts
due to your work
um of scientific misconduct is
increasing so we're being more aware of
it and on the look out for it but from
your perspective do you think in in
general the amount of misconductors
increasing or do you think the problem
is getting better
um
it's hard to know because we can only
catch the tip of the iceberg so
um when I found a paper mill that looked
fairly realistic but um that was a it
was a paper about prostate cancer and
half of the patients were female were
met were were women and you're like
that's unexpected and so you can sort of
see these these errors that they make uh
the paper mills make and you can catch
uh and then maybe you can find other
papers that look very similar they're
written on this template but if they had
not made that error the paper would look
realistic so
um there might be there there might be
an increase in uh in papers and I think
it has to do with the in papers with
misconduct with that are fabricated or
falsified and it it has to do with this
increased pressure to publish that seems
to get you know
higher every year
so an artificial intelligence is going
to
to add to this problem we can use it to
detect maybe falsified papers but we can
also use it misuse it to generate
falsified or fabricated papers you can
you know have a decent text written by
some Bots that looks like a scientific
paper and that probably would pass peer
review and we can also use artificial
intelligence to generate photos or
graphs that look very realistic we've
you know seen examples online Dell E and
this person doesn't exist.com like we
can we can make movies with realistic
looking dinosaurs I mean it gets just
worse and worse and or you know the
images get better and better but the
problem gets worse and worse because we
can no longer you know next year we can
probably know not no longer distinguish
the the dinosaur from you know it looks
very realistic we cannot tell it's fake
anymore you know it's fake but
it's hard to know and so we can use AI
to to generate falsified papers and I'm
a bit pessimistic because I don't think
we we can no longer
distinguish fake from real
and maybe we can still do it this year
but I don't know about next year it's
just getting that the techniques are
getting better so it's very hard to
to tell a fake paper apart from a real
paper yeah no I mean I completely agree
and actually you mentioned Dali and I
was actually the other day in
preparation for this was sort of playing
about to see if it could if I typed in
Western plots with fans it would
actually be able to make something
slightly confessing it didn't be a
breakage of um thankfully but that's at
the moment I mean who knows give it some
training give it some time and yeah it's
terrifying and also I've also seen AI
tools where it's meant to help you write
the paper where you just start typing
and then it just sort of also fills gaps
and I'm like how why would you want that
I mean I I don't know um so definitely
um
yeah quite quite scary but in terms of
um
what I was speaking I mean we've spoken
already about some of the ways in which
we can try and reduce the amount of
misconduct but um in terms of speaking
more I guess to early career stage
scientists do you think there should be
more trainings I mean there was maybe a
slight bit in my um undergrads about it
but that was it we learned about what a
retracted paper is but I guess do you
think that's a lot of incompetency in
terms of like we're just not necessarily
aware of what what's happening
yeah I think some training is is
definitely good I've never had any
training and I feel that most scientists
have an ingrained feeling for what is
right and what is wrong but I do feel it
will be very beneficial if uh beginning
grad students or maybe Master students
would learn about what is accepted and
what is not and I think we're all
struggling including myself I'm
sometimes struggling with questions like
you know you make a graph and you see a
nice correlation but there's one outlier
like what do you do with that and
um I feel as long as you you have you
write in your notes that while you left
out the outliers or you do redo
experiments I feel that is that is okay
but if you do you know if you measure
patience and and there's one patient
that is a complete outlier what do you
do with that that is it's those are
tough decisions and I don't think
there's a right or wrong answers and
but some training on that would be very
beneficial but I also feel we should not
just focus on training beginning
researchers but also focus on what the
the older generation the more senior
persons are doing and I feel there's a
lot of
there's a lot of focus and a lot of
scrutiny for younger researchers but a
lot of the senior researchers appear to
uh you know if they if if some of them
are accused of misconduct very often
they get away with it even though you
see these some cases where there have
been senior people involved in multiple
indications that I was misconduct in
their lab but it's the junior person who
then gets fired or who has to leave
Academia while the senior person
is not punished in any way even though
they're responsible for the atmosphere
and the Integrity of a lab and
mentorship and things like that and I
feel there's a very there's a lot of
blame pushed on Junior researchers
but not on the senior so I feel as an
institution it's good to teach your your
incoming students on how to do research
but you should also hold accountable the
senior people
if they are
showing signs of not being a good Mentor
and maybe pushing their staff into doing
misconduct they should also be held
accountable and there's just not enough
of that
no I agree
um yeah heavily things will change and
yeah probably having you on is to raise
awareness and to get people at least
talk about it
um but also yeah one of the reasons I
wrote you on as well is because as you
mentioned at the start you have
background in microbiome research and so
I thought it'd be interesting to ask you
um given that I've come across a few
websites or companies even that claim
that they can look at your microbiome
and predict certain diets or foods you
should be eating and so I was just
wondering if you could maybe comment on
some of the sort of overhypes or maybe
myths that's around the microbiome space
and what what actual research does
actually look quite promising
well this this is a tough question I've
worked at one of those companies myself
and that company then now got raided by
the FBI and the founders are being
accused and charged of insurance fraud
and so I it's it's a very tough question
I feel that there's still lots lots of
um
lots of things we don't know about the
bacteria and other microorganisms that
live inside of us but I do feel there's
a there's a it's a very promising field
in the end these bacteria can break down
some of our food and they can generate
all these molecules that we
we don't know yet much about we're still
learning and it's it's it's it was a
very promising field and it is still a
very promising field but it hasn't
really delivered what I thought it would
deliver in you know the next five years
or so five years ago
so I do feel we can
it's it's really cool to look at which
bacteria are in your gut and how they
respond to different foods that you eat
like or maybe you take a probiotic and
you might see certain bacteria go up or
down or respond to that or maybe you you
travel and you see your bacteria respond
to that and I think that is a really
cool uh way I you know we I worked at a
company that offered that for their
clients um where you could just order
kits and and sort of see what the effect
was but
then that company wanted to also
uh sort of can we translate that to a
more clinical uh situation where we can
ask we can look at Patients tool samples
and see if they're sick with something
like what is a balanced microbiome and I
I honestly thought I think all of us
thought okay this is a very promising
field and we can make those predictions
but I feel it yeah there's there's too
much conflicted information and so what
seemed to be a very promising field has
not yet delivered but I'm still
optimistic I do feel we in the end we
could go to our doctors and maybe have a
microbiome test done and and learn about
certain bacteria that are implicated in
disease there was just a paper that came
out
a couple of weeks ago showing that a
particular bacterium was associated with
rheumatoid arthritis
and and you know might just be one
bacterium or a group of bacterium and
but it's
it's one of those things there's there's
so many discoveries still waiting to be
done and I feel they're
will get to that point where we can do
diagnostics based on our microbiome but
it has not yet I don't think we can make
a lot of predictions yet we can we can
maybe tell that a person is sick because
they have a microbiome that looks sick
but we cannot really tell what disease
they have and that is but we hoped to um
to solve that you buy them but in the
end that was yeah was a little bit
over-promising and uh of course we hoped
to reach that point but we we did not at
least I I wasn't able to make any
predictions in the two years that I was
there
and and then the the company you know
the leadership sort of went in the wrong
way and and started to think too much
more about making money than about what
the science could actually deliver and
and I feel
the
the developments in this field have been
much slower than everybody had hoped for
I mean I think yeah it's probably not
just the microbien field but some like
other fields as well I guess again like
neurodegeneration
um as let's say we've had hope and then
things don't okay the way we think they
will
um obviously I mean I'm somewhat tempted
to go into microbiome research later in
my career I think it's super fascinating
and as you say I think there's so much
worse so we get to discover
um it's also a massive interest of mine
um but another thing I just wanted to
ask you about is obviously when you sort
of talk about misconducting papers one
thing that
um you get is criticism and obviously
being online and talking about papers
myself
sometimes I also get some criticism and
I just wondering what sort of advice do
you have in terms of being able to deal
with the criticism
well I wish I could tell you that it
doesn't bother me but it does like it is
hard to be criticized one one way that
helps is to look who who is offering the
criticism is it a Anonymous troll with
30 followers or is it a respected
scientist with
you know 10 000 followers and and like
who's tweeting under their own name so I
that is one way to look at it and and
it's amazing especially I feel as a
woman in science if you make some if you
state something online somehow that
seems to attract a lot of trolls and
um I feel and I might be wrong but I I
think a lot of women would agree that we
seem to attract more criticism than if a
man would would have said the same thing
and on top of that we also get
criticized for the way we look or the
way we talk or whatever
uh the what we wear and and you know men
don't seem to have to be getting uh too
much criticism about those things so
it's it's really tough
um and yeah I've been continuously
targeted so I mean I got like
um dozens and sometimes hundreds of
nasty tweets every day uh with you know
you go to jail and you're a field
scientist and
um you know I hope they will rape you
and I hope they will
um yeah I read the most horrible
comments and and it's it's it is
um disturbing and with new leadership of
um of Twitter I feel that we're not
going to that's not going to get any
better like it seems that you know free
speech
um which in my opinion is not the same
as everybody can say whatever they want
but uh it seems that we're heading in a
direction where nasty comments are no
longer moderated and that is just
horrible I mean I trying to report all
kinds of tweets and they never seem to
pass the rules of what is misbehavior on
Twitter so it's only going to get worse
and then yeah it's very disturbing I
I and it's it's I I might get you know
40 likes on a tweet but then if you get
10 nasty remarks it it sort of
doesn't seem to be balanced it seems
that the nasty remarks eat more at me
than than a like of a fan so it's it is
it's tough but helping it helps to look
at who who gives the command
yeah and yeah I'm really sorry to hear
the comments that you do receive
um but I was just um besides talking
about how to deal with criticism Jeff
anymore just like general advice to
um I guess then researchers of any age
and stayed in Accra
um to give criticism or to I don't know
I just generalize criticism
oh well
like I've I've always been very critical
but I um I'm not sure if this is
answering a question but uh I I tried to
do it
politely and objectively so I feel that
helps me you know not get sued although
you know there's threats of lawsuits
every day so we'll see how that goes
but it it helps to even if you're
insulted
to to not choose this to do the same way
to always try to be respectful and to
you know answer to take the high road
instead of the you know trying to insult
back but that is tough and um
yeah so I'm not quite sure if that was
the question maybe should reword it
because I don't don't yeah
um yeah how to give appropriately
criticism but then I guess yeah just
more generally do you have any sort of
General
um advice for those in research how to
how to be a good researcher I said if
that's a better voice to phrase it
um
well don't don't falsify results I mean
always like I I feel appealing to
honesty is something that I feel should
not be necessary I feel most people who
work in science are there to find the
truth and I I you know you you can do
great and uh if you are in doubt just
you know either consult with a more
senior person or at least log in your
logbook in your lab book what you did
why you left left out an outlier why you
choose to start to grab a certain set of
samples instead of other samples like
try to to document that as much as
possible and if you are going to change
the value like like you know leave
traces of what the first value was like
don't try to hide stuff
but also if you suspect that that
another person in your lab or another
group is not honest that is a very tough
situation to deal with especially if the
dishonesty comes from somebody above you
somebody you know hiring rank
and
um I feel you you should either consult
again with somebody you trust who is
maybe on a slightly higher level and can
give feedback
but also document what they ask you to
do if you if you are pressured in doing
misconduct maybe not directly being
asked to photoshop something but saying
like I you know if your professor sent
you an email saying I want those results
to look like that or if they ask you in
person
you can write that back in an email so
okay so we agreed that you asked me to
do that and
[Music]
um
and have that email you know that's a
then now you have a sort of a paper
trail you can maybe forward that email
to your personal email account to have
some proof of that a person asks you to
do misconduct
um and if you try to report misconduct
or suspicions of misconduct again remain
very objective and those cases are very
emotional people are very emotionally
involved but don't make any false
accusations so instead of saying
Professor X is a fraud you could say
well Professor X claimed in this paper
to have used that cell line but they
actually use that cell line and and and
and here's some proof here some copies
of you know the seller in the user so
um that is more objective and and try to
not make any accusations but stick to
the facts and that is sometimes very
hard but I do feel a scientists were
trained to do that so you could appeal
to that and also keep it concise don't
don't send you know your research
Integrity officer a 40-page email
because
that does come across as you know too
long to nobody wants to read that like
can you can you summarize it in a in a
short abstract sort of as you would do
for uh if you would go to a conference
exactly yeah and I think that's really
important advice
um and I just want to say again thank
you for everything that you've spoken
about today I think it's been like
really insightful for me to end
hopefully for my audience too
um and yeah really makes you question
and will definitely make me double think
a lot when I read papers now
um and maybe I'll get I don't think I'll
ever get to your stage of spotting but
um we can try
um
you have you have a couple of decades
still to to reach that level
but yeah um but yeah speaking of um
being able to help support you back
um where is the best place to sort of
help out or to get involved with what
you're doing and yeah to support your
your work
well I'm on Twitter I'm at microbiome
digest without the e after the m
uh and I'm also on patreon so people can
support me with small amounts of money
um and uh you know like I'm happy with
one one dollar or one Euro
um a month uh but of course like not
everybody can afford that and I know
that but I'm I'm happy with any support
but a like on Twitter is is equally
important for me because you know when
when I'm attacked by some some people
who don't like my criticism
um of their company or their Professor
then it does help for me to see that my
work is appreciated as well
it's okay thank you and yeah so thank
you again for coming on and it was just
lovely to have this opportunity to speak
with you
thank you for having me on I love it so
thank you so much
so I hope you've learned something in
this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening